take a look at this tweet from uh Helena
Johnson so let's see she is the
editor-in-chief of the Free Beacon
Harvard to turn to essays it says in
email this is Harvard basically
declaring they intend to ignore the
Supreme Court ruling and use loopholes
to keep being racist watch out the email
says Dear members of the Harvard
Community today the Supreme Court
delivered its decision in students for
fair admissions versus president and
fellows of Harvard College the Court
held at Harvard College's admission
system does not comply with the
principles of the equal protection
Clause embodied in title VI the Civil
Rights Act the court also ruled that
colleges and universities may consider
an admissions decisions an applicant's
discussion of how race affected his or
her life be it through discrimination
inspiration or otherwise we will
certainly comply with the Court's
decision
you see what they're saying there yeah
absolutely they're now going to make
everybody right about their race and
then they're just going to choose people
who they think fit their woke ideology
and it's going to be I mean this is
going to be very difficult to enforce
right because I certainly I don't
advocate for lying in any situation but
a lot of people are just gonna lie a lot
of people are going to write their
essays about how like they were black or
they were Hispanic or whatever when they
were white so that they could get into
the institution some people have
actually done that before some people
have done that by saying they're Native
American I'm not sure if you've heard of
this admissions consultant who went on
the CNN interview
he is Indian
and he said he was black so he could get
into Harvard Medical School oh wow and
then he went on and he's become one of
the leading uh Advocates against
overturning affirmative action he said
this is wrong like I should not have
been able to get accepted just because I
said I'm you know I'm black and now he's
an admissions consultant and helps
people I don't know if he helps people
game the system or whatever he does but
he went on CNN he said we need to
overturn affirmative action and has
become one of the leading advocates in
it but well I suppose the question is
how far will this go because affirmative
action isn't just in universities it's
everywhere it's we have the Press
Secretary of the United States of
America is Simply Hired because she's a
black lesbian woman so the vice
president
I think that's an opinion made by a lot
of people who think it may be the case
I'm talking about specific and overt
examples in in the public where they
outright stated like like for for actual
public jobs they actually put in the
descriptions hey we hire based on these
questions
apply basically the Vice President Joe
Biden said I'm going to get a woman of
color like that's it's from affirmative
action well and this is this is
interesting point right because we're
told affirmative action is good we're
told the concept of diversity hires are
good but if you ever insinuate that
someone was a diversity hire or that
they're in their position because of
affirmative action that's evil wow
affirmative action is good why is that a
bad thing to say Kareem Jean-Pierre may
be the worst press secretary we've ever
seen man at least and I would say she is
the worst In Our Lifetime Jen sackey was
really good at what she did she was
really good like as much you don't have
to like her I think she lied a whole lot
but she played the press That's what she
did really great yeah I thought she was
smart she's gonna Shuffle back on that
bro exactly that's the job yeah yeah she
knows be very smart you know that I
despise it uh I'm not even like when it
comes to Spicer Kaylee Matt Kaylee
mcinay did really really well because
she had the book debunking The lives in
the media that is a fantastic way to
handle it as for Crane Jean-Pierre she's
the worst here's the thing
she was hired by the Biden
Administration
for who knows what reason
saying that she is was hired for
affirmative action isn't is just an
insult with no as far as I know there is
no formal declaration that they were
seeking out to hire a person based on
these criteria it's a weak argument I
have no idea about it we know Kamala we
know they do it but kamalo is an elected
position so even there Joe Biden saying
I want diversity doesn't meet the same
level no what I'm talking about is in
our schools in our fire departments and
our police departments they explicitly
say race as a criteria that needs to end
if leftists want to be racist and then
publicly declare they're racist and then
when it comes to hiring we have to make
that argument we'll make the argument
but right now affirmative action extends
to a whole bunch of public institutions
directly and overtly where the
government literally allows you to take
raise into consideration for hiring for
public jobs that should not be allowed
and this should be the ruling to shut it
down I don't know if it will be though
because this is specifically about
University admissions yeah no I mean 100
I agree with all that I think that there
is a difference between mean a job
posting saying we are going to hire
people based on these racial
characteristics and someone saying
they're going to pick a VP based on
those credentials I just think both are
really scummy and slimy and stupid
well I agree with you it's it's
remarkable to me that there are I don't
I I just don't get it are people the
average person is just stupid and
doesn't care
less person is thinks that if a square
peg and a square hole means that it's
succeeded here's what here's here's how
polling works I have a question for you
Sheamus yes hit me actually let me ask
Ian Ian do you think uh universities
should be allowed to reject an applicant
based on their race no all right that's
a one vote in favor of opposing
affirmative action uh let me ask you
another question Ian do you think that
universities should be allowed to uh uh
uh allowed to approve applicants based
on race if it helps bring diversity and
give opportunity to underprivileged no
groups bring the best people man I do
not care what you look like or who your
dad was this is how the pollsters do it
you go to someone and say should should
Harvard be allowed to let minorities
into the school to help end equal in
inequality everybody says yes
whenever pulser goes out and says do you
think Harvard should be allowed to
reject a candidate based on their race
everyone says no
you see how that work because if you're
allowing someone to come in based on the
race that means you are rejecting
everyone else based on their race quite
literally that means that for in order
for that to exist two applicants come in
a Asian one and a black one and you say
too many Asians not enough black people
that's how it works one would be
rejected so this is how pollsters
operate and this is how the public
operates the left uses this this
language manipulation gender affirming
care like where did that come from this
is what the affirmative action it's
called racist race-based admissions
race-based hiring do you believe race do
you believe we should have uh race as a
criteria in job applications yes or no
no no no aside from casting for a movie
look if you're gonna do a Netflix reboot
right but I mean you know the way you
look not even that in acting it is yeah
and Bolin has to be played by uh is that
what happened or whatever like I don't
know ambulum is a black girl they didn't
move a reboot and they had and they're
doing they're doing another movie with
like a mixed race woman I'm all about
that but you shouldn't have to well
didn't some like Academy Awards or
something say you have to have like a
diverse or minority group represented as
like one of the top characters in the
movie or you're not going to be uh
eligible for one of our Awards that's
how you know if a movie or not though do
you wanna do you wanna uh take the lead
role in my movie about Shaka Zulu
absolutely yeah
[Music]
I feel like I'm too old for that right
never doesn't matter anybody can play
anything oh my God he was a merciless
dude in a good way I mean merciless oh
my goodness this is the Zulu I mean as a
warlord leader like Genghis Khan style
this guy was one of them is it a
surfboard he's holding that's a shield
those dudes real wild man
what was that what was that weapon that
was like a curved stick with a ball at
the end of it
crazy stuff dude uh uh anyway he was
like a powerful warlord but my point is
simply
they will they will like their ideology
makes no sense if we're doing a period
piece from you know 1500s Europe they'll
say oh who cares if it's if it's a you
know a black or Indian person playing
yeah like characters but you're not
gonna cast a Sheamus coggle in his shot
because that would just that would like
that would be racist and stupid right
that would just be racist and stupid but
when you do the exact opposite of it it
becomes non-racist and smart like all
right okay I guess so I thought we were
like bypassing the race thing in 20 2006
I was like man we really have started to
see eye to eye brain to brain
like I was actually getting to a point
where I would just look at people I'd
see their eyes and everything else was
just kind of this gray black white green
blue mesh of color and shade and I'm
just like interfacing with their brain
something happened in I guess Obama
pushed a little bit too much racism uh
subtly when he was in office like the
black kids the black kid and you're like
dude it's just it's not Sheamus is gonna
wake up from the simulation he's gonna
be a black woman why was why is it why
are you picking on me that's always me
no nothing he's good because insinuating
no you know Ian bringing up like the AI
stuff you know if we if we do go
metaverse Ai and all that stuff
people are going to identify as whatever
they want like Rachel dolezal if she was
in the metaverse her her you would you
would meet her identifies anything yeah
well as a black woman and she's a white
woman well so you'll you will have like
white men morbidly obese white man who
identify as as black thin black women
will do that and you'll have like you
know you'll you'll have an Asian guy
randifies as a Mexican dude and stuff
like that like people will just decide
to present these ways in in the AI in
the metaverse well you know it's
interesting because we'll joke about
people like Rachel dolezal right uh and
we'll talk about how ridiculous that is
but I mean really
race is actually on much more of a
spectrum than sex is yeah right you can
actually be half one and half the other
like if you have a if you have a a black
mother and a white father then you're
going to be half black and half white so
those boundaries are actually not as
well pronounced as the boundaries
between the Sexes are and yet we'll say
because of like some infinitesimal
number of people who have uh confusing
Anatomy or birth defects that that means
that that sex is on a spectrum it's
ridiculous yeah like like Rachel if
Rachel Douglas all is one percent black
then is she allowed under that this is
the interesting question no the the uh
no no
um uh it was a college humor I think who
did this the yes yes yes the panel of
Asians if you can identify as Haitian
yeah so it's uh it's a it's a full it's
a full Asian a half asian and a quarter
Asian on a judging panel and a guy walks
in who's an eighth Asian and they're
trying to determine what he's allowed to
do it's like is he allowed to compliment
Asian food and it's like yes but not a
physical anyone there who's more Asian
than you that's right then you have to
ask first and then at the very end the
last gag is a guy walking and he's like
my great great grandma was black and
they're like you're black very different
this is The Melting Pot the United
States it's got to be intentional this
rare push for racism has got to be
intentional it wasn't supposed to be
this way man and it wasn't like this in
the early 2000s at all there was the
Arab racism that's probably what really
started it was 9 11 fear the Arab kind
of mentality they got forced on us 2003
was crazy hyper racism dude people were
Banning Muslims and crap 100 Years of
democrat rule in Chicago and it is
extremely racially segregated they have
done nothing to stop it they keep saying
they're doing things to help people all
they're doing is making it worse yep and
and New York isn't isn't as bad as
Chicago but very very similar in terms
of racial segregation and how the police
handle all this stuff I mean during the
2020 Summer of Love College campuses
started having uh they said if you come
back to school in the fall we will have
black only dorms in 2020 they have
segregated dorms but uh because they're
showing how non-racist they are like
it's it's insane we've done a total wait
we've gone
completely backwards thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time